One of the things we talk about is the
best Spider-Man stories are when Peter
and Spider-Man's worlds collide.
It's been a thrill working on Spider-Man for the first time
and doing it with our longtime partners at Playstation or Sony Interactive Entertainment.
Spider-man is a character that is super
beloved by many people and Insomniac
myself included and we also know that he
has millions of fans around the world, he's
one of the most beloved characters
of all of media period so we felt a lot
of responsibility to try and make a
great experience for players, but
focus really hard on bringing you a kind
of a fresh Spider-Man experience that
respects the DNA of the series and feels
right but also will surprise you in new
ways and it starts with the fact that
this is not an origin story this is not
based on a comic or a movie,
it's a brand new experience starting a 23-year-old Peter Parker who is masterful at
fighting crime and it's gonna have some
great personal relationships.
You're gonna see the Peter's side of it and
you're also going to see the Spider-Man side.
I don't think it was really hard
to decide that we wanted to, you know,
take the best things and our favorite
things from past Spider-Man comics and lore.
There's so much good stuff over decades, you have all these great
characters and Spider-Man has been in so
many different situations and bought so
many villains and fans have many
favorite moments and so we wanted to
honor that legacy and try and do things
that we as fans would want to see while
also providing a lot of Easter eggs for
fans as well.
But we weren't just thinking it had to be all classic,
I mean, if you look at the choice of Mr Negative,
he's a very modern Spider-Man villain
Dan Slott created him I think nine years
ago, maybe 10 now, so he's relatively
newcomer and if you haven't been keeping
up with the comics, you may have no idea who he is,
so it's great to bring him to
potentially his largest audience yet.
It was really important to us to
tell a story that we wanted to tell.
We have amazing ideas, we love Spider-Man,
and as fans if we were gonna sit down
and play like a new
big Spider-Man game, we would want
something that would, you know, feel like
very much like Spider-Man, but at the
same time, be surprising and so it was
kind of just us knowing that if we were
gonna play this game, it's what we would
want.
Creating a 23-year-old Peter Parker
allowed us a lot of things.
that we couldn't have gotten with a 15-year-old one.
Firstly, he's already great at
fighting crimes so we can let players be
awesome at being Spider-Man.
This isn't a game where he's trying to learn his powers
and figure out how to web-swing
and not being good at fighting guys, we can throw you right into the deep end
into some crazy situations because you are a masterful Spider-Man who's been Spider-Man for eight years.
On top of that, there's sort of high
school relationships that you have that
the classic 15-year-old Peter Parker
explores.
we wanted to sort of explore what your
relationships are and what your life is
like after you get out of university and
you start a job while also trying to be a superhero.
A classic thing about Spider-Man is
how to handle the next step of life and
that's something that Peter always has
dealt with whether he's been in high
school or he's in college.
We're just doing that for what it's like when you
finally are an adult.
Well, New York is this like melting pot of cultures so we
wanted to reflect that as accurately as
we could and there's kind of a very
large Chinatown district.
We wanted these characters to still be very authentic to
who they were, like just because our
Peter Parker is 23 years old, he still
should act and feel like Peter Parker
and maybe people are wearing are in
different jobs, like MJ is a reporter at
The Daily Bugle or Norman Osborn as the
mayor, but we still want them to be true
to their actual characters and true to
the character traits that have been
defined for them so that's kind of how
we're blending things and and I think
showing other cultures especially as it
relates to Kingpin or to the city of New
York or to Mr Negative, it's just important to be authentic to their to those characters and that universe.
So we have Marvel's New York, the island of Manhattan,
after the first mission, you
can just swing around and see the whole
swing everywhere all the way from
financial district up to Harlem.
We wanted to have a really detailed city
that feels doesn't just look like New
York but feels like it when you're in it.
This is not a dark abandoned city,
it's got pedestrians and traffic, so
as you explore the city, there will be
additional activities for you to do.
Some of these are little collectibles like
Peter leaves backpacks everywhere
when he goes to fight crimes,
and then he forgets where they are.
Each one has like
a different piece of memorabilia, so to
speak, that kind of tells you a little bit about
the story of his first eight years as Spider-Man
There's other
collectibles too, like there's landmarks
that Peter can take photos of, there are
stakeouts that Black Cat has been up to
but then there's also side quests and
some interesting side missions.
It's a big game and it will depend a lot on how
much side content you do but even if you
don't do a lot of the side content, there's still
a very satisfying and long story there for him.
But one that I really think is interesting and we tried
to mix and tie the story and everything where
we could, is there are these research
stations that Harry Osborn set up as a
project to help clean up New York.
Now, Harry is currently away - Harry is
Peter's best friend - in Europe for studying at school,
and so he asked Peter to check in on his research stations for him.
But little does Harry know
that actually Spider-Man
is doing the checking in and using some
special web powers to help do the
the research that Harry was trying to get done.
We're huge fans of Spider-Man at Insomniac
so we've been working hard on this for
over three-and-a-half years, we poured a
lot of energy and effort into it.
We're very excited for you all to play the
game, try to avoid spoilers,
there are a lot of little surprises and big
surprises still left to be discovered.
and we can't wait for you to play on September 7th!